this is going to get weird I love Bob
Ross he's like do it this way if you
like to if it looks different from mine
it's okay there's something so
hypnotizing about the way he speaks and
it's just so soothing I know he's a
painter but I totally had no idea that
he was dead I thought he had a new
Netflix show so let's do this let's go
right in here just put in a happy little
global so I'm painting like a looks like
a sunset I think I did my darker than
his though okay hold on give me a second
here so he does move quickly sure wants
it to blend now and I don't feel good
about this this is looking good like I
legitimately feel like I'm doing a good
job Bob
[ __ ] Oh God I'm using the wrong brush
[ __ ] all we're doing is applying some
very very basic little shapes think
about the shape of a tree I'll think
about the shape of a tree okay that one
kind of looks like a tree I feel good
about that blending or blending blending
I think we're using the same brush
before whatever reason what I'm doing is
not what he's doing trees look a little
bit like penises but you know what we're
gonna do the left side looks better than
the right side like this looks like
trees this still looks crazy here maybe
he lives a happy little Bush this is
what keeps a little rabbit warm in the
winter it keeps a rabbit warm in the
winter oh wow
this theme is not just the painting
there's life in it I think this is
salvageable if I just stick to the lower
half Bob's voice is what I imagine like
if Mufasa Morgan Freeman and God decided
to teach a painting class I think these
are supposed to be bushes I can't be
sure anymore
if Bob in like the Reading Rainbow guy
did they ever team up because like them
together like if Bob in the Reading
Rainbow guy I can't think its names
Laverne I do oh it's not Laverne okay so
now we're basically making the whole
ground with this nice blue which I'm
finally getting the knack of not having
too much paint I get okay the area's
kind of the bob ross of food
way less likable [ __ ]
what what what my confidence is back
down I felt great and now my oh crap
mine doesn't look like that maybe today
we'll have a big old cabin cabins I was
always amazed by his cabins because like
what he's like three strokes under a
little burner for Cobham touching and
pushing at the same time can we painted
something cooler like a bear oh god I
don't know how to do this I can't even
imagine like if you're watching this i
RL commercial television you can't pause
who did this oh yes I just like the
sound of this the knife is always my
favorite part because he works some
[ __ ] magic with this thing okay so
it's like a Christmas a Christmas
getaway for for me and Bob the economy's
bad so no gifts this year Bob I'm just
not even gonna try the windows because
it's clearly gonna be a hot mess I'm not
feeling great this feels a little bit
crazy he's crazy everyone's crazy I'm
crazy for thinking I could do this they
could call that one finished in fact
wait we're done what thank you Bob I'll
see you next time um okay yeah I think
I'm done
[Music]
I had to pause multiple times and mine
looks like complete garbage after like
an hour
the trees are definitely gonna need some
therapy before they're happy trees I am
most proud of my tree here on the right
it looks like it's ready for Christmas
he has a special place in my heart that
only Bob Ross can have oh it was about
the grind I don't know why this like
looks like a thing like a human person
would be like mmm sure I made this and
how many people can say that thanks Bob
see you next time
[Music]